ladies and gentlemen
please welcome commander joint base
langley eustis
colonel clinton ross united states air
force
good afternoon as you heard i'm colonel
clint ross installation commander for
joint base langley eustis
let me start off with a huge thank you
to our distinguished guests
and the airmen and soldiers who are here
today for this special event
i would also like to take a moment to
thank the staff and the service members
who made this visit possible your
efforts are not unnoticed
or unappreciated in you in making this a
very special event for our first lady
and president and and now
please join me in welcoming mrs brittany
bean and her family
spouse of major nathan bean who's
currently deployed
our first lady dr jill biden and our
commander-in-chief
and 46th president of the united states
joe biden
[Music]
please take seats
early in the obama administration i had
the pleasure of working with then
second lady dr biden and i can i can
attest
firsthand to her sincere passion about
our service members and their families
from wounded warrior events gold star
family recognition
and the joining forces initiative she
has been a devoted advocate to those who
serve
and have served it is now my sincere
honor
to now welcome first lady dr jill biden
ma'am
it's a pleasure to see you again and the
stage is yours
thank you colonel ross and clint it's so
wonderful to see you again
you know when our past last crossed as
clint said you were
serving in the white house military
office and the obama biden
administration was just getting started
and you were
an invaluable resource to my team as we
worked
to serve the military community through
our joining forces initiative
and you know i remember how sweet claire
was when you
um when you brought her to take your
daughter to work day
so i'm truly grateful for everything
that you did to support us
back then and for you and your family's
continued service today so
good afternoon everyone it's great to be
back in norfolk here at langley eustis
for
and for with those who have given so
much
for our country our airmen and our
soldiers
and those who love them the families of
our service members and veterans
the caregivers who lift up our wounded
are ill and are injured the survivors
who grieve those we've lost
you may not wear a uniform but military
families are as critical to our national
defense
as a rudder is to a ship
you support your service member no
matter
where they are you sacrifice
your safety with every move in pcs with
every new school or job
you serve alongside your loved ones
we have an all volunteer force and it
continues
only because generations of americans
see the honor dignity and patriotism of
military service
how can we hope to keep our military
strong
if our service members are forced to
choose
between their love of country and their
love of family
that's why supporting your physical
social
and emotional health is the national
security imperative
your commander-in-chief and i understand
that
this is personal to us and as we begin
memorial day weekend with a community
who feels its
gravity deeply our hearts are with all
the survivors
remembering and celebrating someone they
love
we owe them a debt we can never repay
and we must do everything we can to help
them
carry the weight of their grief and
always
always honor their service
ten years ago first lady michelle obama
and i created joining forces and this
work continues to be one of my
top priorities today we are going to
make sure that our military and veteran
families caregivers and survivors
have what they what you need to survive
our military is a community bound
together
by love love for our country
love for the men and women who serve
beside you
or the service members in your life
and love for the communities that you
all have built together it's time that
our nation
matches that devotion may god bless you
all
our troops and their families
and now i'm excited to welcome our next
speaker brittany bean
in addition to being a mom of three
a veteran herself and a fellow teacher
brittany has navigated much of this
pandemic
while her husband major nathaniel bean
is deployed to afghanistan
with britney service this is their
family's seventh combined
deployment brittany
like so many moms i know
that you are the rock of your family
and that's especially true when you're
parenting
with a deployed partner i want to
thank you and your children
jordan nathan and margaret catherine
for your strength resilience and
everything you do every day
to keep us safe brittany
ladies and gentlemen good afternoon i am
brittany bean and these are my
well-behaved yay and adorable children
margaret catherine nathan and jordan
my husband major bean is overseas in
afghanistan
he has been gone for six months and he
will return in about six more months
about in time for christmas
on this memorial day we are asked to
honor remember
and mourn those airmen servicemen and
women who have paid the ultimate
sacrifice in the performance of their
duties home and abroad
as a veteran myself and spouse to a
service member currently serving
overseas
i am all too aware of the cost these
young men
and women are asked to bear as is
president biden who has suffered a loss
of his own
some of you listening to my voice right
now have also
suffered a loss
i'd like to extend my external and
internal gratitude however willing to
protect the american dream
to keep our nation a beacon of democracy
and hope to others it comes with a great
sense
of honor and pride though i've taken off
the uniform and have transitioned to
being a military spouse
i am still afforded an opportunity to
serve others as an educator at pocosin
elementary school
go bulls
thanks to programs like the cares act
however as most
educators know not all lessons are
retained to the confines of the
classroom
our three children have been benefited
immensely
from the range of interpersonal
relationships they have formed
over the years as military children all
children have lived abroad in the middle
east
traveled all across europe and the
united states
they have had the opportunity to meet
families from walks of life
and many socio-political backgrounds
the military is a global community
community
a unified community and one that i am
proud to have served and continue to
serve
with that i would like to welcome
president biden to joint base
langley eustis and the hampton roads
region but first
when you were elected my husband
said i got to shake the hand of the
president
you gave his commissioning speech at the
2009 air force academy
graduation and i said
i actually get to shake the president's
hand
i win don't you agree thank you
how'd you guys get comfortable
colonel ross plan it's wonderful to see
you again
thank you when our past last cross
as jill said you were serving uh in the
white house
and uh i never thought we'd be standing
here
today doing what we're doing today and
chief master sergeant peterson thank you
and
and to all members of your team who'll
put this
visit together today
it uh it means a lot to jill and me
uh when i was vice president and
as chairman of the foreign relations
committee
we tried to visit almost every major
military base in the country and
is vice president around the world and
you are simply stated you are the
backbone of the country
you're the backbone of the country and
uh
although our son beau was the attorney
general of the state of delaware
had spent uh nine months in kosovo
trying to uh as assistant u.s attorney
trying to set up their criminal justice
system
and i might say i've i can do this with
the military
um i'm going to brag about him a little
bit he's the only
foreigner to have a war memorial
directed to him in kosovo
just below fort bond steel and uh
and the highway the first highway they
built named after the
joseph r beau biden memorial highway
and uh and he was uh he was proud of
hell
cell of his work but then he decided
that i kept on he had contracted uh
exposure to a virus in
when he was in kosovo and in turkey as a
civilian
and uh he came back with a problem
but he kept going to walter reed i
couldn't understand why
he was they finally found it's called
ankylosing spondylitis they finally
found a cure
prevented him from having what they call
bamboo spine
they kept going back i couldn't
understand why i thought i
knew why but guppy went back because he
was trying to get an exemption
to be able to join the united states
army
he was a sitting attorney general and
all my colleagues
the governor and bobby scott and
congresswoman they all know is that
when you do that you join the national
guard and his
unit deployed and he wanted to deploy to
iraq with them
so he literally had to give up his seat
temporarily he could not have any
business
done as you national guard folks know
you can't do any business with the state
if in fact you're now federal property
and so he gave up the seat
and had the courage to uh appoint
the fellow who had been the republican
attorney general as attorney general
while he uh
while he went the proudest thing he ever
did
proudest thing he ever did and he uh
he spent a year in iraq and uh
it was uh it was one of the great honors
it was life
to do it on the bronze star the
conspicuous service medal and other
awards like many of you have
but he never ever talked about it
i remember we had an event at the white
house i shouldn't be talking so much
about my son but i'm not going to
apologize for it
we had an event for iraqi veterans
at the white house and the president
without telling me
jail invited beau to be there with
another
75 soldiers
and sailors and airmen but he wouldn't
wear
any of his decorations
and general ordinano called them and
served under and said put them on
now swear to god
walked out of the vp residence he
wouldn't put him on until then
that's the first time i ever saw the
bronze star
what i'm telling you that is is like a
lot of you
you do your duty you don't expect
anything for it except
you'll have to get a little respect you
deserve so much more
there's so much more
and uh you know uh i'm honored to be
joined today by
governor northam and by two great
representatives of the commonwealth
congressman laurie and congressman scott
and i want to thank thank you for all
you do to represent these service
veterans because they're devoted to you
if the family members the caregivers
survivors
will call virginia home i'm especially
honored to share the stage with brittany
and jordan and nathan and margaret
catherine
i i love those barrettes in her hair man
i tell you what i look at her she looks
like she's 19 years old sitting there
with her
like a little lady on her legs brittany
you're doing triple duty as a veteran a
military spouse and a teacher
and kids thank you for being there for
your mom
i can remember all those times and all
of you remember the spouses when your
husband or wife are deployed every
morning you wake up you say that little
extra prayer
while you're drinking your coffee you
just spend a little more time wondering
and uh you know you make up one percent
of the population
you're defending 99 percent of the rest
of us
we owe you but you do your job so
gracefully
you hardly ever say anything about what
you do
but it matters it matters to your
families
for that time we're sitting across from
an empty chair
kitchen table a dining room table
those birthdays or christmases or
holidays
where they're gone you know there's a
famous english poet who said they also
serve
who only stand and wait
also serve only stand and wait
i know uh major beans having been
deployed to afghanistan during the
pandemic has only made everything
much harder during the pandemic
i want to thank you so much your entire
family's service to our country
you're all incredible you so
underestimate
how important you are there's nothing
that jill and i enjoy more than spending
time with our troops
here and abroad we're stationed here in
the united states are deployed around
the world i've been
in and out of iraq and afghanistan over
20 i think 25 times
and i've seen i wish everyone could see
what you do when you're there
i wish they could see every day
how you saddle up and you jump in that
cockpit
just see no you're just just doing your
job
not to mention all the troops i've had a
chance to visit the middle east in
europe and the indo-pacific region
we've traveled all over till's traveled
all over me
on her own visits to service members in
iraq
i think she's the only second lady ever
to go in the middle of a war zone
because she wanted to be there and see
it
i always want you to know
always that the issues you and your
family
are facing we need to know how we can
support you better
i mean sincerely from the bottom of
hearts but you're better
there's a reason for that i said we
biden's are proud to have
family and military and our son beau's
service was uh
was among the achievements that i said
he was most proud of
my heart swelled semen uniform
when i went into iraq i was there five
times when he was uh in baghdad
and uh i
i remember first time i saw him
yeah his name was hunter so what the
hell happened he said dad i don't want
anybody to
give me any special favors because my
vice president's my dad
he got permission to put a different
name tag on it
i also remember what it was like to
listen to him talk about the needs that
people had
when he got back home
but all the folks he served with who
came back with
post-traumatic stress and he was back
being attorney general having to deal
with it
but here's the point you do so much
and you ask for so little
you know our experience is a fraction of
what so many of you and your families
have gone through
family like brittany and her kids do an
absolute best
america has to offer our heart
our honor your solid steel spine
so my message to all of you is quite
simple
thank you thank you
i thank you for your service just thank
you for who you are
because it's contagious thank you for
choosing
a selfless service to your country
i know we have mostly soldiers and
airmen in attendance today but
there can be a lot of friendly rivalries
on the base
each branch has its own proud cherished
traditions and culture
i know how proud langley is of the
premier fifth generation f-22 raptor
wing
oh god i'd love to go for one of those i
asked
i'm your commander-in-chief why the hell
can't i command you let me go up with
you
you know that won't let me do that but a
ford eustis hosts one of army's busiest
airfields which is led by the air force
primarily used by the navy
it's all about as joint as it can
possibly get
every day the more than twenty thousand
members of the air force and army along
with civilian personnel
come to work with a shared mission
no matter which branch of our armed
forces you proudly represent
you're part of the greatest fighting
force in the history of the world that's
not hyperbole
the greatest fighting force in the
history of the world
you're integral to the most powerful
nation in the world
there's been no army navy air force ever
like you or marines
here at joint base langley eastern you
enable
the success of our mission around the
world you provide intelligence support
and air power you ensure our soldiers
and airmen
are are ready trained to deploy the
cocoons around the world
including this year adhering to coba 19
safety protocols and quarantines before
troops ship out
in order to minimize the spread of the
virus
know that many of you deployed
yourselves probably more than once
over the past 20 years our volunteer
force and our military families have
made incredible sacrifices for this
country
early in my term as vice president i
traveled overseas i'd sometimes meet
servicemen
and women who were deployed their fourth
fifth sixth time
remember going into baghdad and these
members and those who had to fly in
you do those circular deals so we
wouldn't get shot at
and we wouldn't get hit i walked up in
the cockpit of a silver bullet that they
had me in
and i asked i said how many there were
five people in the cockpit
time load master as well so how many is
this your first tour
nobody raised their hand how many the
second tour
nobody raised their hand third tour two
raised their hand
fourth tour two raised their hand fifth
tour
one razor no other war
have you gone in served
got back up again and go back again
and again and again
once once
wiping the blood off the seed and up
armor humvee
is enough to get you focused then to
saddle up
next time and go back and back again
you're incredible you're incredible
the country they owe you
and they're this time they're more
appreciative
my generation you didn't come home get
off an airplane on a uniform
in an airport coming back from vietnam
people treat you with respect but they
have no idea the sacrifices you make in
theater
as we bring we get close to bringing
down the longest war
draw down in american history a true
presidency afghanistan
want to recognize this significance to
what all of you the united states armed
forces have accomplished in the past 20
years
went to afghanistan with a clear purpose
to get the people who attacked us on 9
11
and prevent al qaeda from using
afghanistan as a base from which to
attack america in the future
you achieve that purpose you achieve
that purpose
year after year deployment after
deployment american troops pursued the
terrorist threat
to some of the most unforgiving terrain
on the planet
i have now had the pleasure as they say
of being in every part of afghanistan
from the fobs up to the konar valley
down south looking at all those poppy
fields
and all in between it's one
godforsaken landscape but you all just
showed up and did your job
and helped make sure there hasn't been
another attack from the homeland from
afghanistan
the last 20 years and you never gave
up until we delivered justice osama bin
laden
i got criticized after 9 11 for saying
we'll follow the son of a bit his gun
to the gates of hell till we get him
it's exactly what you did it's exactly
what you did
you got him and now as we draw down
we're also going to focus on the urgent
work of rebuilding over the horizon
capabilities
that will allow us to take out al-qaeda
if they return to afghanistan
but the focus on the threat that is
metastasized
the greatest threat and likelihood of
attack from
al qaeda or isis is not going to be from
afghanistan
it's going to be from five other regions
of the world that have significantly
more
presence on both al qaeda and
organizational structures including isis
we're going to update our security
stance and turn our forces to the
threats that will dominate our future
to ensure the security of the american
people for decades to come
but we'll never ever ever forget the
terrible cost
that we've paid as a nation many of you
likely have lost friends and colleagues
in afghanistan and iraq
i know this is personal to you
especially
as you're heading memorial day weekend
we as a nation will always remember
pay tribute to those we lost
after i announced my decision to end the
war in afghanistan the first thing i did
was visit visit section 60
of arlington national cemetery
just walk through those headstones
seen all those stones
our son did not die in iraq but he came
back
went as an incredibly healthy young man
and came back with
a severe brain tumor because his hooch
was just downwind from those
burn pits i don't know if that's the
reason
but he came home it was just a matter of
how long he lived
i still carry with me every single
solitary day
i have my staff for the last since the
war began
i have my schedule on the back of my
schedule
it says u.s daily troop update
u.s troops died in iraq and afghanistan
6927
not over 6 000.
total fallen angels across the board
over seven thousand
every one of these lives lost is a
tragedy
an empty seat at the dinner table
a missing voice at the holidays
everyone i'm left behind a whole
community
not just one whole community
we can never repay that debt but i
promise you this
to all the gold star families across the
country
we will never ever ever ever forget
each year memorial day offers us a
chance to reflect on the enormity
the sacrifices that generation after
generation of americans has made
and the responsibilities that we bear
citizens bear in return
i've said many times it used to get me
in trouble 25 years ago
30 years ago in the senate so america
has many obligations
we only have one sacred obligation
obligations to our children to the
elderly and so many more things
only one sacred obligation is to prepare
you when we send you into harm's way
with
everything you need care for your
families when you're gone
when you come home care for you
and your families and the needs that may
be a consequence of the war
we owe it we owe it
to you and particularly owe it to the
memories
to affirm the very best of what america
stands for
to uphold honor and democratic values
for the foundation of the strength of
this nation
you know i sometimes get criticized for
saying what i deeply believe having done
this for the bulk of my life
we're in a we're in a battle
between democracies and autocracies
the more complicated the world becomes
more difficult it is for democracies to
come together and reach consensus
i've spent more time with president xi
of china
than any world leader has for 24 hours
of private meetings with him
just an interpreter 17 000 miles
traveling in china and here
he firmly believes that china before the
year 3035 is going to own america
because autocracies can make quick
decisions
but america is unique
of all nations in the world
we're the only nation organized based on
an idea
every other nation you can define
by their ethnicity their geography
the religion except america
america is born out of an idea
we hold these truths to be self-evident
but all men and women are created equal
endowed by their creator
with certain inalienable rights
including life
liberty etc
none of you get your rights from your
government
[Music]
you get your rights merely because
you're a child of god
the government is there to protect those
god-given rights
no other government's been based on that
notion
no one can defeat us except us
it's an idea the generation of patriots
have fought and died for it and defended
i know that's a conviction that each and
every day
you all share that's why you joined up
while you run around danger and duty
calls
it's my greatest honor it should not
surprise anybody it should be anybody's
greatest honor
in all of life to be able to serve as
your commander-in-chief
no greater honor so
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for spending this time with me today
and thank you for your commitment
to our country
because without you as i said i'll be
under i began
you are the spine of america
the spine
i can't tell you
how much it matters i think you
underestimate
it's the consequence of who you are and
what you do
thank you may god bless you
may god protect our troops thanks
[Music]
foreign